all right we've just gotten our first
full look at the upcoming sequel to
fantastic beasts and where to find them
fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald and there are even more
references and easter eggs in this thing
than there are words in that title
seriously this may be the most packed
teaser trailer we've ever seen who will
help me sum up all this Wizarding
goodness I'm only one man
okay sorry about that I feel better but
let's just dive in here's a little
background before we get into this
teaser trailer breakdown it's important
to know or remember the backstory of two
of our major players Albus Dumbledore
and Gellert Grindelwald once close
friends together they plan to find the
Deathly Hallows and use it to destroy
the International statute of secrecy
which keeps wizards from revealing the
magical world to muggles their plan was
to create a benevolent society where
wizards ruled over muggles in harmony
but their plans changed after a
three-way duel with Dumbledore's brother
Aberforth that accidentally led to the
death of Dumbledore sister Ariana then
Grindelwald fled Britain and continued
to plan the revolution behind the scenes
then the first fantastic Beast movie
happened now you're all cut up okay on
to the teaser trailer we open in a
setting that after eight movies ought to
be at least a little bit familiar that's
right it's good all Hogwarts a
contingent of wizards probably led by
the Minister of Magic at the time Hector
folly have arrived to take a meeting
with young Dumbledore played by the
young Pope at this point he was only a
lowly Transfiguration professor The
ministers of magic asked Dumbledore
about Newt Scamander and why he's
heading to Paris
Dumbledore acts like he has no idea and
says that Newt doesn't follow orders
well but then we see new piecing
together a postcard telling him to head
there these were probably instructions
from Dumbledore who's just playing dumb
with the minister's oho Albus liar and
confirming the suspicions Dumbledore has
in fact been guiding nude as we can see
they've been meeting up on rooftops like
Batman the film is called the crimes of
Grenaa wha but you may have noticed we
haven't seen her
about him yet or his crimes but we do
get this quick shot of Johnny Depp is
Grindelwald standing next to devoted
follower vin de rossi air as you can see
there in front of a huge assembly of
wizards and witches renault while
bringing together a powerful group of
followers would help explain pretty much
everything else that happens in this
trailer but especially why Dumbledore
insists that new choses aside and help
him in the coming fight we only see
Greta Walden close up in the trailer
right at the end we know that at the
beginning of the film he has to escape
the custody of the US magical Congress
so that's probably the jailbreak we're
seeing don't you think the trailer has a
ton of characters in it some of whom we
recognized but many who are new to the
on screen Wizarding World Dan Fogler
returns for the new film as Jacob
Kowalski as he's coming with Newt on
some kind of wild adventure possibly to
Paris does he just hang out with all
these magical beasts now that guy's
living his best life Catherine
Waterston's back to as Tina Goldstein
looking more fashionable and confident
this time around her sister Queenie also
returns she's wandering around some very
official magical office with creature
designs on the ceiling seems like this
maybe is the Department of the
regulation and control of magical
creatures but I mean who can tell that's
Ezra Miller returning his Creedence bear
bone it almost looked like he died at
the end of the first fantastic beast but
a single little piece of his obscures
form made it away from that scene so
there he's on the rooftop in this shot
once more unleashing his obscurest
powers this is a dark form of magic that
brews inside of certain wizards who fear
and suppress their powers if credence
has figured out a way to actually
control his obscurus he could
theoretically be one of the most
powerful wizards in the world and a key
ally Dan Newton Dumbledore maybe this is
why they come to Paris in the first
place
to collect him or maybe they just like
croissants and cigarettes you don't know
that figure next to credence on the roof
is probably important as well
it's claudia kim as maledictis she's a
performer in that magical circus les
cirque arcana's we see for a quick
moment now maledictis were told suffers
from a tragic blood curse that turns her
into a beast and check out this early
promotional photo of claudia kim and
character note the scale patterns on her
leggings
plus here's an old ad for
Carquinez that was released as part of
the film's marketing apparently they
have a snake girl a lot of potter fans
theorize this means maledictis will one
day turn into a serpent or maybe newt
will help her before that happens you
don't know did you spot zoe kravitz
apparently attending some kind of fancy
party she's playing lettle estranged
distant ancestor to Voldemort's
confidant Bellatrix Lestrange knowing
that family she may not be one of the
good guys just throwing that out there
Oh real quick if you remember the photo
from the end of the first fantastic
beast it seems like Newt has a crush on
her
go get her Newt we're rootin for you
Newt finally toward the very end of the
trailer we see Newt and another man
casting some kind of fiery protection
spell in a churchyard or cemetery that's
actor Callum Turner who's joining the
series as thisis newts brother he's also
let allah strangest boyfriend which is
probably gonna get awkward down the road
what with her probably beating evil and
family trees are only one connection
this new film is making with the beloved
potter franchises of old let's go back
to that a Hogwarts seen as Hermione once
read from Bathilda Bagshot Sesenta book
Hogwarts a history Wizards can't just
operate on to Hogwarts ground due to
security conditions also it'd just be
creepy just operate and everywhere now
it's possible that rule was established
after the events of this film though it
seems kind of obvious
maybe they instated that rule because of
something that happens in this film we
just don't know
check out those students watching from
the window above are they the ancestors
of some of our favorite Hogwarts heroes
honestly they just look like some random
kids to me in one of the trailers more
mysterious shots a figure uses a
deluminator to put out the lights on all
the street lamps this is actually a
device that Dumbledore invented and he
eventually between zone deluminator
to Ron Weasley in the Potter series so
it stands to reason that it's him using
the deluminator here or maybe he gave it
to Newt he's a generous sort speaking of
new we see him writing some kind of
fantastical undersea creature we've
never actually seen before it could be a
hippocampus a combination horse and fish
YUM I mean cool a model of one was
instructed to be used as an ice
sculpture in Harry Potter and the Goblet
of Fire remember that big Yule Ball
scene but it was too large so they
didn't end up using it and that
concludes this TED talk about all the
thousands of notable moments we found in
a two-minute Harry Potter teaser trailer
thanks for spending your entire day with
us and let us know if you somehow found
something else on this trailer that we
didn't notice because that would be
amazing
oh we should have said fantastic damn it